boom
work
is hard
hey everybody how's it going my name is
mayuko and welcome back to my channel
the sponsor of today's video by the way
is felix gray so stick around to hear
more about their blue light glasses so
in tech and other places also a lot of
people are doing work making stuff that
probably has never quite existed in the
same way before and so naturally in the
process of making something new and
novel and unique we clash stuff happens
work sucks now i'm somebody who has a
lot of identity in her work and so
whenever something challenging happened
at work it really sucked like it would
be all consuming i would bring it home i
would cry i wouldn't be able to get past
it in like a helpful and healthy manner
i was reminded of all of this recently
when i was talking to a friend earlier
this week she's in her first year of
working and she was telling me like all
the different things that are like super
frustrating and wow it brought back like
so many memories of like my first years
of working and it also gave me a sense
of just like oh all these situations and
things that used to get me really
frustrated
don't as much anymore like my demons are
kind of different now when it comes to
work and i think it's because i've
learned a lot about working in general
because i've been working full-time for
like almost 10 years now learned from my
own experience i've learned from my
seniors my managers and also from other
people's mistakes so much so that these
lessons have kind of become like my
guiding lights for when it comes to work
i think of these things like pretty
subconsciously now but it definitely
directs like who i work with how i work
and what i work on side note i love
talking about these kinds of things like
how to work well how to get other people
to work well and working through like
difficult challenging situations between
people who make stuff together i feel
like is actually like just so
interesting so if you're someone who's
like going through it right now at work
then this one's for you the first of
these guiding lessons that i learned is
that everyone comes to work for a
different reason in any and like really
all of the work that i've done i've
worked with people when you go i thought
you were software engineer and i thought
all software engineers do is code not
work with other people which yes as a
software engineer i worked with a lot of
people i didn't just code like a lot of
my job was collaborating and working
with others and quite frankly working
with other people has also been one of
my biggest stressors at work like they
can just get on your nerve they can be
mean and they can act in ways that are
like completely unexpected that throw
your groove off but
we need to work with other people to do
stuff like i need it i think it's
actually one of the most challenging but
also rewarding things to like work with
others to learn who they are what
they're good at what motivates them to
work and like fostering a deep bond over
time i feel like is one of the most fun
parts about work but when people are my
biggest source of stress i always try to
remember that everyone comes to work for
a different reason i mean if you think
about it everyone comes from a lot of
different backgrounds academic
backgrounds previous work cultural
backgrounds different co-workers and
managers that help them to be who they
are today and realistically everyone's
coming to work for a different reason
too whether that be stability or pay or
learning or growth or because they don't
have anything else to do as do you you
have a reason for going to work and what
you want to get out of it and so
naturally because all of us are coming
from different backgrounds and coming to
work for different reasons it's only
natural that you're not going to see eye
to eye on certain things for example
some people want to work quickly and get
a lot of stuff done like that's the way
they measure their impact other people
want to craft something great and really
take the time to build something awesome
and that's the way they want to measure
their impact and then there's others
that want like a good balance between
the two whatever that might look like
for them with all of these clashes what
makes working easier over time is to
figure out how to work with different
people with different backgrounds and
different motivations as someone who has
a lot of identity in my work and
honestly has really really high
expectations of myself in doing the work
it can be really frustrating to me to
work with someone who doesn't have that
when i clash with those people i would
literally think things like why don't
you care more or like wish they were
just dedicated in the same way that i
was but in reality everyone is dedicated
they're just dedicated in different ways
and it shows up in different ways
everyone comes to work for a different
reason and that's okay
everyone still deserves to be there
because they were hired for their own
skills and talents and perspectives that
overall make the team better i think it
just can be really hard to see where
they shine if all you see is where they
don't which brings me to my second
guiding lesson you decide who you give
your energy to when you know what you
want out of work and you also know what
another person wants out of work then it
can be easy to figure out how you might
work together maybe you have the same
goals or sometimes you have completely
opposing ones and of course in order to
figure out someone's goals you do need
to build a relationship with them i
don't usually ask them outright like why
do you come to work but it is something
that i start to figure out after working
with them over an extended period of
time anyway i found that if mine and
someone else's goal match then we worked
really well together i mean don't get me
wrong like i work well with most people
but i do know that i have a really hard
time working with people who don't
communicate clearly and you know there
were times at work where i worked with
people like that and it would be really
hard to work with and it would stress me
out a lot i would think things like how
can i help them become like better
communicators or what could i just about
my communication style more than what
i'm already doing to meet theirs so i
would do a lot of adjustments and
tinkering just to work well with
somebody which is also kind of related
to i want them to like me and i also
want them to be happy but i think that
maybe now that i'm further in my career
i also know where to stop i know that
after a certain amount of energy and
investment that i put into a
relationship if it's not working i let
it go because at the end of the day you
can't control people like even if you
really genuinely want to help them
if they don't want it then they're not
going to change so i find that a much
better use of my time and energy is to
spend it on myself and others who are
going to take the energy and make
something of it i just realized that
it's not worth making everybody happy or
like make everybody like me because at
the end of the day that's not my job
title i have a job to do and so i spend
my energy much more wisely alright so at
this point i wanted to say thank you to
the sponsor of today's video felix gray
so i wear these glasses all the freaking
time and they're from felix gray these
are the blue light glasses that started
it all felix gray set out to create
eyewear that would improve daily screen
time and now they're on a mission to
create a better relationship with
technology and these felix grey glasses
can filter out 15 times more blue light
they can make screen time harsh on the
eyes and be disruptive to sleep
literally wearing these glasses while
i'm on my computer while i'm on my phone
while i'm on my ipad has super helped
because my prescription like my eyes are
so bad y'all that like if i'm on a
computer for too long i feel it in my
eyes i get a headache and it really
hurts but because of blue light
technology i also have a little bit of
magnitude in them they've really
improved my experience in using
technology these by the way are the
rollings in amber toffee in the low nose
bridge fit felix gray offers classic
frame styles made from acetate and hand
finish for a durable lightweight and
really comfortable pair of glasses the
blue light lenses are available in
non-prescription or prescription so
start the year you're off on the right
foot with felix gray try felix gray with
their 30 day money back guarantee okay
so my next lesson is one of those things
that's like a north star for like when
i'm like really going through it at work
it's that everything is a learning
opportunity even if it sucks in the
moment this is really really hard to
internalize because when you're going
through it it just sucks like you're
just angry disappointed
sad upset frustrated you name it and
this is something that i can confidently
say now because i've been through a lot
of these challenges and i have learned
from every single one and now because
i've proved to myself that that's true
it's a lot easier to remind myself that
everything is a learning opportunity
even when i'm going through it so if
you're early in your career this is just
one of those times where i'm just going
to say trust me you are absolutely going
to learn something from this and there's
nothing in life that challenges you that
you don't learn from because here's the
thing and this is my last guiding
principle trust that your challenges and
hardships will definitely amount to
something there are some days when these
challenges at work felt like they
weren't amounting to anything at all but
the way that reflecting works is that
when you look back on those like really
challenging moments you realize what
you've learned and then also how they've
shaped you to be who you are today i've
learned from working with different
kinds of people what kinds of people i
like working with and what kind of
people i don't like working with i also
learned what kind of team and project
structures i like and don't like too and
honestly all of those things have
influenced things like what company do i
want to work at what kind of role i want
next what's the nature of my work and
who i want as my next manager i mean i
know that like i'm incredibly biased in
saying this but all of the things and
challenges that i've encountered as a
software engineer have made me and
allowed me to do this like make videos
like be an influencer which is not
anything that i ever would have thought
of before
but i just had to trust that things were
going to work out and it is it did and
you know what even now i'm not at any
sort of peak i still
experience challenges every single day
like literally every day i talk to scott
about a new crisis that i'm having so
like i'm still going through it at work
too you know i like to think of it as
like i've climbed a certain set of
mountains and because i've climbed those
mountains i can now see what other
mountains there are to climb and i can
choose which ones to climb on sometimes
they'll come at me without me knowing
but because i've already climbed those
mountains
i think i'll be fine with those in front
of me because you know what challenges
and hard times and times that suck at
work are natural it's a part of the
process like things can't always be rosy
and perfect and amazing it just
things happen and you have to work
through them and so i hope that these
guiding lessons that i learned
throughout my career will help you too
and if not
scream at a pillow or something i don't
know cry it out watch a really sad movie
watch a really intense action movie
that's going to take you out of your own
self and kind of get you lost in
escapism i found that that also works a
lot as well so thank you so much for
watching today's video i have a lot of
information and experience and thoughts
and stuff in here that sometimes i don't
know how exactly to share but i hope
that this format worked for you oh also
let me know in the comments down below
any guiding lessons that you have when
you do work that help you through these
tough times don't forget to subscribe to
my channel and i'll see you next time
bye
[Music]